so how mirror we're so lucky to have you
here and I thought we'd take this
opportunity to take a trip down memory
lane for the French women's Chess
Championships because you have won a ton
of those titles Thank You Jen for
reminding me that they play chess some
time ago
yeah won six titles and it is actually
such a nice experience because I think
okay win in a chess tournament is
already a miracle so and since I was a
kid I was trying to well to target the
stars so like one title second title
third title first title fifth title
sixth title and then I just didn't know
what else to do of course I want to
break the record but well now I'm here
with you and I dedicate my life more to
the chess commentaries so what's the
record six titles also yes sir well I'm
sure we are sharing the title lists of
him like the record with Sofia Sofia me
I write a very strong player from Franz
young player as well now the French
women's championship dates back to the
20s and there have been some really
fascinating historical figures or whose
lives have intersected with history
who've played in this event
well actually I've met one of those
figures the legendary Madame shoulda
dissidence and she was such a great lady
as we say in French LeGrande um and she
won her first French title women's title
when she was 17 and actually then she
decided to never play it again and she
dedicates it's like her life well to
chess and Klain nationally you know
Championships Open Championships so this
one thing we share with her as well
because like I played those twice it was
tough but it was a very nice challenge
and she was also the first woman ever to
play in the Olympic team like French
Olympic teams so I think this is very
inspiring like for us and then it was
Pia Kremlin guy I suppose and then Judit
Polgar so
and of course the history that was a way
too short of era manchak but yeah this
this is a great story of the first woman
ever to play in the open section of the
Olympiad that's incredible I mean of
course you gotta figure environment you
can and died so tragically she also
would have played in the Olympiad at
some point but you know I I think that's
just an inspiring story and you said
that she played in the French
championship open section just like as
you did a couple of years now tell me
when you had to decide whether to play
the opens of the women's was it a
difficult decision or were you just like
I need to get in there with the toughest
players well at the beginning I was
actually playing only well actually my
first French championship was an open
one so it wasn't even a choice because
at that time I was strong enough to
compete in this competition so I
prepared for months because I wanted to
be up for a challenge and actually I did
quite good but I think madam should
addition as she played so many of those
she played a lot of strong tournaments
as well and and then she also played in
the candidates in 1952 like women's
candidates we are certainly going to
talk about the woman's cycle later and
she was such a role model for so many
generations in France and then she
dedicated her life to a chess club named
Chi ISA and I have a lot of stories
about this one because she was
organizing a traditional blitz
tournament on Saturday and then like so
many players wants to play this blitz
tournament Lee I remember joy let's say
telling me a lot of stories about that
like when you win you go to Madame
shidae she would write like disco the
results on a piece of paper and but then
you would have to say
Antoine madam should they you know you
have to announce the victory and so so
many great how do you say I want in
chess as you can you again yet again you
have learned that one guys so another
story of a grade a great historical
figure in chess you know
I hadn't heard of until recently I was
made aware by a thread by Benjamin Porto
and there was a story in Europe a Scheck
about a Holocaust survivor who went on
to win the French women's championship
and when she got out of Auschwitz she
was 25 kilos O'Mara I mean that is
within inches of death no doubt I mean
25 kilos we're we're Americans we don't
use those standards so what does that
mean that's like 52 pounds right yes and
what struck me in this story is not only
that she survived and then she went on
to built a very meaningful life and to
be like a source of inspiration for many
but she's alive yes none of it I mean
like during this but she learned how to
play chess you know during this tragic
period of her life and then it's
probably also something which kept her
life because there are a lot of stories
also like of Russian prisoners you know
back then so like in the gulag so like
when I know the chess kept them alive
and this was such I don't even know like
such a inspiring story as well I talked
to Victor Coach know about this you know
and his wife Petra so they told me how
she survived so yeah chess can keep you
alive and there was a tough moment
certainly like a like religion has
helped so many survivors but
unfortunately you know a lot of her
loved ones passed and you know such a
story of resilience and great I read her
autobiography that she did with a part
of the Holocaust survivor project and it
was so moving because her parents were
so loving even doting one might say just
adored her and you know she knew to
notice that something was wrong when
they picked her up from summer camp and
she they didn't give her the normal hugs
they were very preoccupied and like her
accounts are filled with such touching
details like that about how on the train
to Auschwitz with her mom her mom had a
single backpack with her belongings and
in it unfortunately her dad had already
succumbed to illnesses because you know
he was in
ghetto and there wasn't any way for him
to get the proper medical attention so
I'm in this backpack
she kept his bells report cards which
were of course stellar thinking that
somehow in the camp like this would
could be used you know to like show I
have a very intelligent daughter you
know that was not what was awaiting them
unfortunately you know this is you know
is such a tragic story because like we
don't have to forget and this is our
history but on the other hand it it
gives us strength you know it's exactly
the story of resilience and it she
became an historic figure of a woman's
chest you know and she won she went on
winning the French champion isn't it
cool that like this incredibly inspiring
survivor like you won the same title as
she did like I thought because I want a
couple US women's championship and
there's this great lady
Sonya Graf who also won and I just find
that really cool like that's the history
of chess that you can associate with
these grand figures in history well
sometimes I feel that that's not enough
because they had such a difficult life
and they like they accomplished so much
so like sometimes I feel that it's so
little just to win like a chess
tournament but on the other hand like we
dedicated our lives to chess and so the
game of chess which has given us so much
and to like I believe to all the kids
around the world so it can it can be
such a source of beauty
so it's esthetical beauty and extremely
helpful in well in your life and I mean
one thing that you know during World War
two a lot of Chess Championships got
canceled breaks and US Championships and
French Championships just kind of
showing like that this light of chess
which connects people and shows us that
there are so many more similarities
between us and differences it it
evaporated to a large extent during
those years it was not as prominent of
course there were more important
priorities for countries than hosting
their national championship but it
really makes you appreciate these times
of prosperity that chess has given so
much attention
and appreciate like the values behind
that yeah especially being here in San
Luis you really treasure
I think this that here chess has been
developed and supported and not only the
internationally renown tournaments but
school programs you know Scouts programs
as I understand and some like what was
the last event it was the police academy
and kids you know so chess is a real
educational tool and it's also a game
which federates I think like anyone can
play and that's the most important so
and girls can play it that's like I
remember when I started to play chess I
was alone and boys were around me so I
had to fight you know for well for my
survival on the board and that builds my
character so that's it
I mean chess connects us and certainly
some stories that will never forget to
tie into French women's championship as
we have the six-time champion here in
st. Louis to ride some commentary of the
Karen Scott thank you all Miera these
are some moving stories thank you Jim